Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for coming to
this session. My name is Massimo Loda.
I'm a professor of pathology at
Weill Cornell
Medical Center in New York,
and
I'll be chairing this
session. We have a five-minute
introduction from me, and then
the three speakers will follow
that. And
we will have five minutes of questions at the end of each
presentation, and then a general Q&A
session at the end of the entire
presentations.
Also,
I want to urge you, when you ask questions, to come to the
microphones, or you can use a QR code and ask questions
through
the computer, and we'll find them over there.
The sessions are being streamed as we speak.
So if we can have
the
next
presentation, which is a short five-minute presentation.
I can't seem to advance the slides here.
Oh, here we go. So I'm going to start with some definitions since we're
talking about generally microenvironment and
organotropism. So by microenvironment, we
mean a network of
immune cells that we will not be discussing, at least not
in detail, stromal cells, which will be discussed,
vascular structures, extracellular matrix component,
and a variety of other cells.
There'll be a strong component on metabolism that George is going to be talking
about. And then for a definition of organotropism,
I would say it's a consistent preference by tumors to colonize a
specific distant site,
which is shaped by a variety of factors, anatomical
constraints, molecular crosstalks,
metabolism, and specialized stem cells and
microenvironment.
The session will examine how
this emerges in primary tumors and in
circulating tumor cells, and how
some determinations are made as to where
the tumor goes.
Also, permissive niches will be discussed, and
organ-specific microenvironment that will shape the metastatic
potential
mimicking the environment
at the metastatic site. Technological
advances will be discussed,
and
potential vulnerabilities will be
also discussed. What will not be discussed are stem cells,
which
I want to give you just a
little preview because
they
are not
the topic of this
session. But
recent papers in Nature and in Nature
Medicine by Matt Greenblatt has shown that there are new
skeletal stem cells that determine
the
stem cell population in bones, and
as a result, determine also the
dorsal-ventral compartments
in the vertebral column, for example, and that
determines where tumor cells go. I will give you
just a small example, and I'll urge you to go and look at these
papers if you're interested. This is just one example from these
papers where he transplanted spinal
stem cells into a hind leg of a mouse or
a long bone stem cells, and tumors had
twice the
tropism towards
the ventral versus the long
bones. So this has
great implications for
metastatic tropism, but it's not a topic that we will be discussing today.
Today, we'll have three speakers, two great speakers,
and me.
I will start
with the first
presentation on stromal cells, which is a topic that we are
interested in. And then
George Poulogiannis from ICR in London and Cory
Abate-Shen from Columbia University
will be talking.
So
I will start with
my first presentation
next.
So we have been working on stromal microenvironment for quite a
while, and
I hope to show you that this is
in the primary tumor,
an environment that portends for the tumors to
be
metastatic to bone and specifically in prostate cancer, but I will not
focus only on prostate cancer. So the outline of the talk
is general concepts,
some histopathology, because
it's important to see what things look like in different tumors, and they're
very different.
Desmoplastic stroma, as it predicts
molecularly metastatic disease.
And then I will use, as I said, prostate cancer as a paradigm
to show you this.So
stromal factors at primary sites have many
functions. So physical factors,
there are talks today and tomorrow on
what this does on mechanotransduction and limiting
physically,
tumor movement, metabolic factor, which you'll hear
next, modulation of immune response,
and then direct communication between the stromal cells and
epithelial transformed cells nearby.
So fibroblasts, as you know, are derived from mesodermal
mesenchyme.
They play a very important role in wound healing,
where they undergo a phenotypic differentiation towards a
contractile myofibroblast, and then they start
release cytokines and chemokines, for instance, TGF-beta.
Stromal cells also generate extracellular components, which are very important, as
I'll show you later.
And then,
the stromal cells undergo a phenotypic
and a molecular
change towards cancer-associated fibroblasts, or CAFs,
which communicate directly with tumor cells, and they're
different. One caveat is that clinical trials
targeting the stromal component have not been very
successful, which will give us an opportunity now, we hope,
to change this paradigm
once we know more about these cells.
So here is a cadre of cells in the
microenvironment
of prostate.
And what we're going to be focusing on is
smooth muscle
cells and fibroblasts. What do they look like?
So on top you see,
on the left and the right, two prostate cancers, one
that has no desmoplastic reaction, where the tumor cells just invade in a
morphologically normal stroma. And on the right,
one that has a strong desmoplastic reaction, the bluish
cells around the tumor is what we call a
desmoplastic stroma. On the bottom left, you can see
a low-power view of a breast cancer, where you see
the fibroblasts that pull the tumor
out and actually pull the skin,
if it's close to the skin, giving
a
peau d'orange type of appearance.
And on the bottom right is a pancreatic cancer,
where the majority of the cells in the tumor are actually stromal
cells, up to
80%. So that's what they look like.
But what spurred us into this? So these were experiments
done a long time ago by Jerry Cunha, tissue recombination
experiments under renal capsule, where he put together
urogenital mesenchyme, which expresses androgen receptor,
together with urogenital epithelium, which does not express androgen receptor
at the beginning, and showed that
it is a wild-type AR-positive
urogenital mesenchyme that gives rise to the prostate.
If you use mesenchyme from testicular feminization
or a mesenchyme where the androgen receptor is mutated,
you don't get a prostate
phenotype. These were important experiment.
In addition, what he showed, that in the presence of testosterone and
estrogens as well, because estrogens play a role as well,
when you use immortalized BPH1 cells, which do not have androgen
receptor,
and treat them with testosterone plus
estrogen, only in the presence of
wild-type urogenital mesenchyme, these give rise to tumors that are
rather big, as you can see here.
Subsequently,
Dr. Ittmann at Baylor
and others, and Gustavo Ayala as well, showed that
the amount of stroma shown here by
this blue stain,
as it increases, it portends a poorer
prognosis
and biochemical recurrence in this case.
They went on to look at the molecular analysis
of this by arrays in those days and showed
that the CAFs
adjacent to tumor were very different from normal stroma,
and many of the genes are
involved in neurogenesis, axonogenesis,
et cetera, which will become important later.
In pancreatic cancer, there's other cells, like pancreatic
stellate cells, that undergo changes.
This is just an example. Dave Tuason has done a lot of work
in this area. But for example, here, these quiescent
stellate cells
get activated, and through paracrine and paracrine interactions,
they change these myCAFs, the myofibroblastic CAFs, into
iCAFs.So
what happens in the stroma of pancreatic cancer?
So cancer-associated fibroblast
heterogeneity is central.
myCAFs are
changing and shift
away from the tumor. iCAFs substitute and then start to
secrete things like IL-6,
CXCL12 with cognate receptor
in the epithelium, which is true in the breast
as well, and portends to triple-negative
breast cancer bone tropism.
And then
antigen-presenting CAFs appear, and these modulate
T-cell responses as well.
So these stromal signals induce invasive and
stand-like tumor states. What we did in prostate cancer, we asked the
question, what happens in benign
prostates without tumor, in prostates with tumor
in the stroma away from the tumor, and in the stroma adjacent to
low-grade and high-grade tumors?
The high-grade tumor being the one that metastasized generally to
bone. By gene expression profiling, you can't read this, but you will
see that there are many more changes that occur in the stroma than in the
epithelium
in gene expression space.
And these changes occur--
Different sets of genes change over time as you
progress, so to speak, from the healthy stroma all the way
to the
high Gleason metastatic disease.
This
group of genes that
is associated with high-grade tumors is actually
an interesting group of genes because it has
what we call a bone-like signature,
osteomimicry.
So when we actually separated the low grade, the
non-metastasized versus the high grade, the metastasized,
we found a signature shown here. And on the left, you can see
the one in the teal color are
all genes that are
expressed and secreted by osteoblasts.
And these are primary tumors. The ones in the circle are
actually in a signature that is used by Oncotype DX.
Three out of three of the stromal genes are these genes pointed out
here. And this signature, just by itself, in a different
cohort on the right, as you can see here, the Mayo Clinic cohort,
is
significant to predict metastasis.
Roughly at the same time, Colin Collins
in
Vancouver,
did an experiment where he took five different areas of a prostate,
made PDXs, and showed that three out of the five or two
out of the five were metastatic and the others were not, derived a
signature, and again, it was a stromal signature that if you take the
first 100 genes, this was almost
overlapping with our signature that we did in a completely different
experiment. And you can see here that this
predicts
metastatic state.
To go further, we tried to do
RNA-seq in a variety of
mouse models and then compare them
to human to identify what happens in
stromal cells and what their phenotype
was. So we took the TMPRSS2-ERG,
PTEN knockout, high Myc, and
then N-Myc overexpression tumor,
which sort of
is a progression towards more and more aggressive tumors all the way to
neuroendocrine prostate cancer. Did RNA-seq.
As you can see here, the amount of stroma increased
as the aggressiveness of the tumors increased.
When we looked at the stromal fibroblasts
alone,
we identified eight clusters
of fibroblasts,
some of them common to all
genotypes and some of them specific to each
genotype.
When we then cultured the genotype ex vivo with
normal fibroblasts, these
induce a recapitulation of the fibroblast
gene expression profile. Here's a TMPRSS2-ERG circled here
of these clusters one and three, and then
here is the neuroendocrine
epithelium that changes the fibroblasts into
what
looks like the fibroblasts of the
transgenic mouse that overexpresses N-Myc, suggesting that
it is the epithelial cells that drive
the fibroblasts. The TMPRSS2-ERG, for example,
is
a very common translocation, but it does not have an epithelial
phenotype. But the first phenotype that you see is actually stromal.
You can see the amount of stroma that there is
here outlined. When we compare then the
single-cell RNA sequencing to human, whether you do
bulk on the top left or whether you just look
at TMPRSS2-ERG, because that was the only genetic alteration that
we had in the human,
you recapitulate largely the gene expression profile
that you see in the mouse.
So that was interesting to us. Then
what we did is we compared theThe
genotype of the
fibroblasts that are associated with the
highly metastatic tumors and compare them to
humans
in the bone metastasis, and showed remarkable
similarities between the two. And once again, a lot of the genes
were pro-osteoblastic. So it seems like the primary
tumors creates an osteoblastic environment that then
prepares the tumor to
metastasize to bone. And here are some of the osteoblastic
genes, periostin and others. I'll focus on
periostin for the sake
of time. Again, this tested by
Marchioni's group and Mohammed Omer in
a large data set unrelated to
ours, showed a significant prognostic
metastatic
problem.
So periostin is very important because it is one of the genes
secreted by osteoblasts, but it also is a ligand for
alpha V beta 3 and alpha V beta 5. And so we
concentrated our interest on this gene
and showed that in both mice and
human, the amount of periostin was much higher in
neuroendocrine prostate cancer, which is more metastatic,
in the stroma than in adenocarcinoma.
In addition, it was mutually exclusive with
androgen receptor in the stroma, which is what
Jerry Cunha showed more than 25 years ago, that it's
androgen receptor in the stroma that dictates
what the epithelium does.
When you look at this in a TRAP model, which is a model that
eventually
develops neuroendocrine prostate cancer, you can see that the periostin is
adjacent to both primary and metastatic
sites where neuroendocrine prostate cancer is
expressed.
So to go further, we wanted to see if
these fibroblasts were actually in the primary
tumor adjacent to neuroendocrine cells
and if they were communicating with
the alpha
V beta 3 and alpha V beta 5, which we found
by CellChat in our
single-cell RNA seq analysis. And in fact, if you go
and look at distance and measure the distance on an individual cell
level
between periostin expressing
fibroblasts and neuroendocrine cells, you can see that there's a
highly significant correlation
between
the two.
When you go and look at bone metastasis,
these TRAP model, the
areas that are neuroendocrine go and localize
very close to periostin, shown here in
green, and express all the neuroendocrine markers that
you are familiar with.
This is true in humans as well. So if you look at primary tumors
on the top here and metastatic tumor and measure the distance,
the distance between periostin positive cells and
neuroendocrine cells is high in the primary tumors, but
even much higher with a greater
delta here in the metastatic setting.
We also obviously want to do the functional
analysis, and we recreate the microenvironment with
epithelial and stromal cells,
organoids and stromal cells, and look at induction
of neuroendocrine phenotype by
either giving co-culturing with
TRAP fibroblasts that express periostin, shown here, and you start
to express
FOXA2 in this case,
or you can just give recombinant periostin and
you induce a neuroendocrine differentiation.
This is one thing that you cannot do
ex vivo is to induce neuroendocrine differentiation.
So this happens in vivo, so
the microenvironment is important, and we think that periostin plays a
significant role. The reciprocal
expression of AR and periostin is
shown here in the clusters that are associated with
the Nmyc-overexpressing
mouse by spatial
analysis. So we think that there is a correlation
between the two. And in fact,
in our lab,
Filippo Pedersoli has
co-cultured the DKO
fibroblasts from
David Goodrich lab, and showed that
by
chromatin accessibility, this has changed
completely by the presence
of fibroblasts that are associated with
metastasis. Sorry.
No, I was going the wrong direction.Here we
go.
If you then go and look at motif analysis, what
you start to lose in these fibroblasts is the AR
and GR
motifs, and you start to gain AP1 motifs in
these fibroblasts. So there is a change that
is induced initially by the genetically
altered epithelial cells to the stromal cells
that then changes the androgen receptor
signaling and upregulates periostin and
is permissive to organotropism.
So
these are just highlights of some of the
areas of stromal analysis
that we have done and many other groups are doing, and
I'll just
pause on the conclusions here. First is that mouse
models do recapitulate what we see
in human to a large extent, so it can be used to
infer what happens in humans.
There are mouse models, as I said, like Tempus to ERG, that do not have
an epithelial phenotype but start to have
a stromal phenotype as the first
area
of change that
happens.
We do think very strongly that periostin is
associated both with
neuroendocrine differentiation and organotropism,
and we're looking at the difference in liver versus bone
right now
of tumors that do or do not express periostin.
And then a stromal signature can be used in primary
tumors, and it's a signature that is
bone-forming signature or
bone-like signature that is associated with
bone metastasis.
I just wanted to thank a lot of people that did the work, Hubert
Pakula, Mohammed Omer,
Filippo Pedrazzoli,
Nicolo
Fanelli, and
Ryan as well. So thanks for your attention.
I'll take questions for five minutes, and then we move on
to the next speaker.
Thank you.
If you have questions, please use the microphones.
Thank you. That was a great talk. I have a question regarding the
tumor-produced ECM proteins. So many recent papers are
saying that the tumor cells themselves can produce a rich
amount of stromal proteins like collagen and laminin.
And recent
from Dr. Tuveson's lab, the study also showed that in pancreatic cancer,
tumor-derived ECM factors have correlated much
better with poor survival. So what do you think
that applies here?
What comment would you have on that, whether stromal-derived ECM
is distinct from the tumor-derived ECM, and whether that
could be the reason why the targeting has failed for now?
Yeah. So
I can speak to
prostate cancer and
some of the examples that I showed.
The fibroblasts produce, for instance, periostin, but this is deposited in
the ECM. And these fibroblasts, these particular
clusters of fibroblasts, have different collagens than the other
fibroblasts that are associated with adenocarcinoma.
So all of those are deposited in the ECM.
We're now measuring
what the role of the ECM itself is versus the
fibroblasts themselves. And yes, they do create a
barrier
for sure, even for immune cells.
But that's another area of research that we're trying
to pursue, but we're not very far with that.
Sure. Thank you.
Okay. If there are
no other questions,
then I'll
move to
the next
speaker who's
sitting here, George Paul Janas. He's a group leader
in the Division of Cell and Molecular Biology at ICR in London.
He
studied
early on the
genomic alterations in colorectal cancer, then pursued his PhD
work in
computational biology, and then I met him in
Boston when he was a post-doc of Lou Cantley.
And he's going to be talking to us about the
metabolic
alterations that lead to organotropism. Thanks.
Thank you. Thank you very much for the kind introduction, Max, and
also the organizers for putting together what I think is a very
stimulating meeting for the next few days.
I would like to start by
saying that for many decades, we told ourselves a
deceptively simple
story about cancer metastasis, that it is all
about aggressive tumor cells
escaping the primary
tumorSurviving through the bloodstream
and ultimately disseminating into metastatic
organs and conquering distant organs.
That model
shaped how we studied
cancer, how we designed new drugs, and
in general, how we perceived the
prognosis of
cancer patients.
But it also trained us to look almost exclusively at the seed,
at where metastasis is likely to be coming from,
completely underestimating the biology of the soil.
The big question that has been emerging through the past few years is,
what if metastasis is not just a story of aggressive
tumors, it's not just the story of brute force, but rather
it is also reflecting how
invasive cancer cells might be, but also a
story of permissive tissues. So it is not just
a story of cancer invasiveness. And the classic
metastatic cascade remains essential, but current thinking
increasingly emphasizes that metastasis
reflects interactions. I think Max gave a very nice
introduction about how tumor cells
interact with the stroma.
And I think the main thing we have missed and why
there has been this misconception is that
the simple fact that metastasis is not random.
And I'm giving here an example of
breast cancer metastasis,
where we
clearly know that
breast cancer cells do not metastasize
to all organs at the same rate, at the same frequency.
So breast cancer cells show
striking preference for metastasizing
to the bones, lungs, brain, and liver, and this
pattern is highly reproducible and predictable.
So the question that I think we should be asking is
why these organs? What is unique about the biology of these organs?
And traditional explanations have actually
focused on trying to understand mechanical factors,
blood flow routes, vascular architecture, and physical trapping
of circulating tumor cells. But mechanical factors alone cannot
really explain organ selectivity.
And really, metastatic success also requires that
disseminated cells
survive and grow in a specific soil.
My lab is focused on studying metabolism, which is
probably one of the most important things in the soil, in the organ that
cancers metastasize. And why metabolism
matters for organ preference? Well, first of all, it is really important for
the arriving cells because they must be able to maintain
their ATP production under different oxygen and nutrient conditions.
It is also important for their biomass synthesis, for proliferation,
especially when it comes to nucleotides and amino acids.
They need to find ways to balance their redox,
especially in oxidizing niches like the lung or
brain. And
they also need to be compatible with stromal and immune metabolism
in the different metastatic organs.
Equally,
if not more important,
though, on how permissive the
organ of metastasis is going to be
when it comes to metabolism, is what the metastatic organ provides or
restricts. And characteristic examples are
the brain, where there is low lipid availability, low serine,
and also the constraints of the blood-brain barrier.
In liver, we know that there is hypoxic and glycolytic
adaptation pressures.
There are very nice examples indicating that extracellular
pyruvate in the lung and the oxidative environment can
favor serine pathway use. And last but not least,
there are site-specific responses to amino acid depletion and stromal support
in the bone.
So there are numerous examples emerging in the
literature showing how metastatic cancer cells require their
metabolism
for successful dissemination to specific metastatic organs, and
that creates novel dependencies, and that creates novel
vulnerabilities.
And I'm showing here a characteristic example from Matt Vander Heiden's
lab,
who has previously shown that HER2 positive breast cancer
brain mets, unlike extracranial tumors, adapt to the
brain's lipid-poor environment by upregulating fatty
acid synthesis and desaturation.
And as a result, this creates a novel vulnerability to inhibition of FASN,
revealing a site-specific targetable metabolic
dependency.
Another example is a beautiful work coming from Sarah
Maria Fenn's lab that has shown that breast cancer
cells from lung mets this time rely on
pyruvate to drive collagen-based remodeling of the extracellular
matrix. So they are heavily dependent on this enzyme, pyruvate
carboxylase.
And not only that, but breast cancer cells from lung mets depend on
MCT-dependent import of pyruvate and also
serine biosynthesis-derived alpha-ketoglutarate to maintain mTOR
signaling and
sensitivity to an mTOR inhibitor,
rapamycin.So the pattern is consistent.
Metastatic success is not about brute force.
It is all the growth signaling nutrient requirements that are
markedly different in the different metastatic niches,
when they are compared to the primary site, that can really
determine targetable metabolic vulnerabilities.
More recent work emerging from
Van der Heijden and other colleagues indicates that
no single nutrient explains all metastatic
sites or organotropism. And what was rather surprising from
this work is that depleting serine and glycine in vivo
reduced metastasis in
many sites, including bone, kidney, and ovary, but not
uniformly in brain, liver, or lung.
Equally, when it comes to asparagine synthetase
dependency, this varied a lot cell line by cell line and
also metastatic site. Of course, there were a few more
generalizable
observations from this work, and the ones that are
worth noting are that
there seems to be,
across all metastatic sites, a marked dependency on de novo
pyrimidine and purine biosynthesis associated with DH
or DH and GART inhibition. And purine synthesis,
in particular, emerges a broad requirement for metastatic growth
independent of tissue nucleotide abundance alone.
We were quite keen to address computationally whether the
transcriptomic and the metabolomic signatures of the primary tumor
can actually tell us something about
both whether how metastatic the tumor is likely going to be, but
also what is the site of metastasis.
And in order to do that, we used a few data sets,
like the MetMap data set, comprising of more than 500 cell lines
with known metastatic index, and first selected
the transcriptional and metabolic features that more
strongly associate with metastatic index.
When we applied machine learning algorithms to predict how
metastatic or non-metastatic new cells are
going to be, that were not included in the training set, we
observed that we can predict whether
the cell line or a tumor is likely going to metastasis with quite a high
accuracy, more than 85%, 86% to
be exact, when we use all the features.
And surprisingly, when we
did this analysis only this time with the metabolic
genes, the accuracy increased even further, further
emphasizing how important metabolism is
in determining metastatic
potential. What was
less, though,
clear and more difficult to predict was the site
at which those cells and tumors will likely metastasize
based entirely on the transcriptomic and metabolomic signatures
of the primary tumor.
And I think part of the reason why this is the case is
because there are very few matched
primary and metastatic sites, especially when it comes
to metabolomics.
In fact, to try to be able to address this, we developed
a new tool that hopefully will be available very soon, a
platform called MetaboForm, that infers tumor
metabolomes from transcriptomic signatures.
This is using a combination of both machine and deep learning tools.
And I'm showing here a representative example of a heat map of
liver metabolomics
compared to different metastatic sites to appreciate how
marked the differences are, and this actually correlate strongly
with some of the published metabolomics data sets in these tissue types.
Another thing that is quite important, another important factor to consider when
applying such tools to predict how certain tumors are going
to behave is that tumors are actually metabolically
heterogeneous.
And I'm showing here a representative example of a breast cancer section
following mass spec imaging analysis that we performed
from work
funded by the Rosetta Grants Challenge Project, where
we profiled actually a large number of breast cancer tissues.
And the mass spec imaging allowed us to really capture the
metabolic heterogeneity within tumors.
And I'm showing here a representative breast cancer section where every color
represents a metabolically distinct subtype within that tumor, and you can
clearly see that the tumor cells in the periphery of the
tumor invading through the normal stroma indicated in blue
here, has a very unique metabolic signature.
We were quite keen to follow up some of these observations in
the lab and made use of a model that was actually
generated in Clare Isaacs lab at the ICR of
organ-specific metastatic clones.
This was derived from the
MDA-MB-231 triple-negative cells, which were
initially injected in the primary site.
And they were selected in vivo.
They waited for the cells to metastasize at
different organs and then did an in vivo selection three times.
We were rather struck to identify that when we harvest these cells and put
them back into the same
media conditions in vitro, they retainVery
unique metabolic signatures, with the most apparent being the one
coming from the bone,
that you can clearly see here
when we profile the transcriptomics and the metabolomics profiles of
these cell lines.
Integration of this data actually indicated that the pathway that shows the
biggest difference is alanine, aspartate, and glutamate metabolism.
And indeed, we were able to show that
when it comes to glutamine-related genes, it
shows marked differences between the bone and the other metastatic
clones. And of course, glutamine is the most abundant amino acid in the cancer
cells and is used for many different things.
It is a carbon and a nitrogen donor for a lot of different
things. So it's difficult to try to identify
what specific role
it is needed in the context of bone metastasis.
But to substantiate some of these observations, we went on
to further show that indeed, bone metastatic cancer cells are
very sensitive to glutamine dependency when it
comes to bioenergetics force analysis, and they are
more sensitive to both glutamine deprivation and treatment with a glutamine
antagonist, DRP 104. And this appears to be
specific with glutamine.
What I mean by that is that when you deprive actually cells of another substrate
glucose, there is no preferential effect in the context of
the bone when compared to the parental clones.
Glutamine import is regulated through
key enzymes, key transporters, SLC1A5,
SLC38A12, and the export is
regulated by SLC7A5. So we were quite keen to follow up
and see if those show any differential expression or activity in the
context of bone metastatic cancer cells.
And so that indeed,
the levels are higher, but
inhibiting one of these transporter, at least, is
really tricky. The cancer cells have the ability to
adapt, and
so inhibition with a relevant
inhibitor of the
transporter didn't really show any preferential activity.
However, we were able to show, using stable isotope tracing
analysis, that indeed bone metastatic cancer cells show higher
glutamine uptake. And this was actually validated in another model
generated in the 41 when comparing the bone
metastatic versus the primary parental cells.
One of the most important roles of glutamine is to
form an alternative substrate for the TCA cycle
through
conversion to glutamate and then alpha-ketoglutarate.
So we did some stable isotope tracing analysis
to carbon label glutamine, and then follow
the tracing
patterns of some of the downstream metabolites,
and were able to show that the flux of glutamine to the TCA
cycle is indeed higher as determined by
M+4 labeling of some of the key TCA
substrates.
And then went on to show if there is any differential effect on
GLS1 specifically, which is the key enzyme converting
glutamine to glutamate. And saw that while there are no changes
in protein or mRNA expression, there is a marked increase in the
activity of GLS1, which again, was validated
across different models. And that makes
cells vulnerable to both inhibition
of GLS1 with a
CBA39 inhibitor
across both models.
So targeting GLS1 actually reduces
proliferation and invasion capacity of
bone metastatic cells.
And we are in the process of
trying to do this now in vivo.
But the take-home message that I was hoping to finish with
is that metastatic organotropism can be viewed as
a sort of a metabolic coding problem, that different
organs reward different metabolic solutions.
And I hope I have convinced you that an integrated pipeline combining
all this omics analysis, computation, and clone-based
functional interrogation offers a practical route
to identify organotropic liabilities in metastatic breast
cancer. And with that, I would like to thank you for your kind
attention.
Particularly, I would like to thank
Jessica and
Theo, who did most of this work, as well as all our funders for their
support and all our collaborators, without whom we wouldn't be able to do
that. Thank you, and we'll be happy to take any questions.
Great talk. As a kidney cancer biologist, I'm always
interested that for mechanical blood volume reasons, the
kidney should be as metastatic as the lungs or the
liver, and actually has a very similar metabolic profile to the
liver and does similar homeostatic things.
But yet clinically, we rarely see mutations to the kidney, and
kidney cancers harbor strange organ-specific metabolic
mutations, VHL, FH, S DH. Do you have any
insight into why the kidney is so
"hostile" or what's restricting metastasis
there?
I don't if I'm honest.
I think though, in order to be able to answer this question would
be to be able to do the profiling of
these specific organs, including kidney, to be able to get any further
insights. Yeah.
Thank you.
Fantastic talk. Thank you.
I was just wondering, have you ever tried to check whether the abundance
of glutamine in bone is high, or there are some stromal
cells in bone which are now rewired to produce glutamine
to fuel these tumor cells?
Yeah. It's a great question, and we are actually currently doing some of these
experiments and
co-culturing also these cells with
osteoblasts to be able to see if
this is what could be driving their preferential
sensitivity to glutamine metabolism targeting. Yeah.
Thank you.
Hi.
When you did your map showing the metabolic changes in the
heterogeneity of the tumor, did you notice any correlation between collagen
density or composition of the ECM?
Yeah. It's again, a great question, and in addition to
special transcriptomic analysis and the metabolomic
profiling, we actually did a lot of site of analysis, but
we have not finished the full analysis of this.
But it is definitely something that we will be testing, and
also whether there is any specific signature associated with, let's say, an
immune cell population and so forth.
Okay. Thank you.
Sure.
That was a really good talk. I have two questions.
The first one is,
because your bone metastatic cancer cells are showing
more dependence to glutamine addiction,
so I was wondering whether, do they lose the ability to make their own
glutamine, so the de novo glutamine synthesis that they
do through GLUL or glutamine synthetase, do they lose that
protein compared to the primary tumors?
And-
Sorry, the question is whether they lose the ability to metastasize if
you target this pathway? Sorry.
So do they lose the
protein? Do
they not synthesize their own glutamine anymore when they
show the more-
No.
-tropism to bone?
No, they do. What we saw is that they
actually saw higher flux of glutamine and higher metabolism
of glutamine. So for some reason, they depend a lot on glutamine.
So it's more extracellular glutamine rather than the intracellular glutamine
that they make?
Well, we don't fully know, but a high
flux of glutamine could also affect the
microenvironment-
Mm-hmm.
-and this is something that we are
testing at the moment.
Oh, thank you, and sorry, one more question.
Because osteoblasts are also dependent on glutamine to be
differentiated, I was wondering how the intense
requirement for glutamine by the cancer cells, how that affects their
formation or their function.
Yeah. It's a great question again.
Something we haven't, I'm afraid, looked at, but it might also affect
the differentiation of adjacent cells, so including osteoblasts-
Mm-hmm.
-which is something worth investigating,
definitely.
Yeah. Thank you so much.
Two quick questions and...
Great. So great talk, and thank you for sharing your data.
I was curious about when you--
So these bone metastatic lesions in the
cells, when you re-implant them back in the in vivo setting, do they
have tropism to the bone, one? And two,
in the cases where they are not necessarily in the bone, do they still retain the
same metabolic phenotype?
They do.
Overall, we saw that they have an overall higher invasive
capacity.
But definitely, they show higher tropism to the bone compared to all the
other metastatic loads. Yeah.
One more quick question, quick answer.
Sure.
Yeah. Sorry, this might be a naive question, but vascularization
is a basic feature of all tumors. Is there
a way or do we know which
metabolites or nutrients
the metastasis cannot get from the
vascular structure, have to rely on the local environment, and which are
not?
Yeah, and I think some of the work that some of the people I mentioned in
my talk have done is to also look at
what nutrients are surrounding the tumor through doing metabolomics of
interstitial fluid, which I think is very powerful in addressing
some of these questions. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks very much. Sorry to cut off the question earlier, but we'll have more
time at the end of the last talk. So last but not least
is Cory Barret Shen,
who is
known to you, Professor of Medicine and
Molecular Pharmacology and Systems Biology at Columbia
University.
Her work in mouse models and prostate cancer
and many other areas is very well known to you.
I just want to remind the group that she was
elected to the National Academy of Science and Fellows of AACR
just yesterday. So welcome, Cory. We're looking forward to it.
Yeah, and if you're wondering why I was late for this session, it's
because it was our first fellows meeting this morning.
So I ran out of the fellows meeting to get here in time.
So sorry to
have missed the first talk. But anyway, I'm really glad to be here.
Thank you all for coming to this great meeting.
So what I'm going to do is, to complement the two previous talks, I'm going to tell
you about how circulating tumor cells find their way
to distant sites. Where the hell do they get home?
I have consulted for Boehringer Ingelheim, not related to anything I'm going to
talk about today.
So,
really one of the things that I wanted to start for this
education session is to think about why we need to study
metastasis in vivo. And it's extremely-- There's a lot
of questions about why use mouse models and things like that.
Do we need mouse models? Why don't we do everything in patients?
But,
the reality is, is that metastasis is something that occurs
in the whole organism. You can't tease out any
part of it without studying it in the whole organism.
And so I think that the main thing to think about is that
it's the entire ecosystem in the entire body
is where metastasis is occurring.
And that's why it's essential to study metastasis
in vivo in orthotopist models.
And, the other way to think about it is that
metastasis, of course, by definition means
traveling to different sites.
And
so that's another reason why it's very important to study metastasis in the
context of the whole organism. And what we've done with the
approach that we've taken in my laboratory is to study that in the
context of circulating tumor cells, which are really the
conduits from the tumor to the distant site.
And what I'm going to tell you about today is some work that was spearheaded by a
very talented member of my group, Arianna Giacobini,
in which we've done molecular and biological studies
looking at circulating tumor cells to figure out how they find their new
homes.
So the model that we've been working in is prostate cancer.
And as many of you are aware,
men with prostate cancer that have
locally invasive disease,
do very well. In fact, many of them don't even need treatment.
However, once the disease progresses to metastasis, it is
lethal. And there are currently no cures for metastatic
prostate cancer,
and so this is really, really important aspect of prostate
cancer to study.
So the approach that we've taken, as I alluded to, is to develop a series
of genetically engineered mouse models that recapitulate
prostate cancer metastasis, actually full prostate
cancer progression from non-metastatic to highly
metastatic disease. And we can model that
both temporally to look at intratumoral
heterogeneity and across different phenotypes to look
at
intratumoral heterogeneity. So both
intratumoral and intratumoral heterogeneity.
And the important feature of these models,
as you'll see, is that they involve a lineage mark.
So we can mark the tumor cells over time and
space. I think this pointer is working, right?
So we can mark the tumor cells over time and space,
and follow the cells from the original
epithelium
to develop tumor cells and
metastasis. And what Arianna did was to realize
that while those cells are in circulation, we can follow those
as well. So we can identify circulating tumor
cells by virtue of the lineage mark.
Now, why is that so important? Because there are a lot of ways to look
at circulating tumor cells. Okay.
You can look at them based on their size or their shape or their
expression of surface markers. But each of those ways of
looking at circulating tumor cells requires that you know something
about them. So therefore, you're already looking at a subset of
the cells. If you just look at all of the cells that came from
the primary tumor, then you can study heterogeneity.
And that's the real innovation of what I'm going to tell you about today.
That we can study heterogeneity because we could look at all of the
cells and see how they're managing.
Okay, so the models that we're looking at, I'm not going to spend too much time on
this slide, but you can see that we can follow in vivo,
the fluorescent phenotypes, okay, which we of course,
molecularly, histologically characterize, although I'm not going to go into
that. I'm happy to answer questions.
And you can see the primary tumor in various metastatic sites,
developing metastases. Okay. And in early
stages,
these mice do not develop overt metastases, although I
have to say that they develop micromets to the bone, we've
characterized that. And then we have models that develop
metastases to lesser degrees and also with different
organ site specificity.
So again, allowing us to look at temporal as well as
phenotypic differences in metastasis progression
and correspondingly, the circulating tumor cells from those
contexts.
So the way we isolate the circulating tumor cells, it's actually really quite easy.
We collect the blood, we look for the fluorescent cells, which are live
cells. I can show you that they are in fact circulating tumor
cells because we can look at them with different markers in the
cytospin.So what did we learn about that?
I'm going to show you examples. Primarily in my slides, I'm going to show you
examples looking at
temporal.
So these are the early
mice, and these are the late mice. And you can see that there's a large
number of circulating tumor cells in these mice,
and that matches actually almost
exactly with the metastasis score.
And when you look at a correlation, it's very, very high.
So there's circulating tumor cells that emerge
that are very closely related to the metastatic
phenotype of them. But are they really circulating tumor
cells? Are they just not some green fluorescent cells floating around?
So I'd actually asked that question.
We took the cells, re-implanted them into host mice,
normal host mice, wild type host mice, non-tumor,
and then looked what happened. And you can see that even at the very small numbers
of cells
cause lethality in these mice, and large numbers of cells
cause lethality very, very quickly, and that lethality is due
to metastasis, as you can see both by looking at the metastasis
score as well as the overt metastasis themselves.
So these are in fact circulating tumor cells.
But it's really hard to study them if you can't keep them and
study them in some way. So Arianna had the very thoughtful idea
that she could try to make organoids out of these, and by
making organoids, we would be able to study the biological
properties of the CTCs. But you can
ask, do those CTCs retain the features of
the tumor from which they were derived? I'm going to show you that they do.
But first, I'm going to show you that we can actually make organoids.
Again, those organoids are green, and you can see a very high rate
of organoids
relative to the number of CTCs. Very closely
related. So we have a whole series of organoids from
these mice.
So as I mentioned, the real key thing was, do those organoids
recapitulate features of the primary tumor from which they
were derived? And actually, they are remarkable similarity,
both in respect to the molecular features, as
you can see from the gene set enrichment, as well as pathway
analysis of the leading edge of those.
Very strong correlation. But what I really like is this
experiment here in which we can take the
organoids and we can grow them in vitro, or we can
allograft them. And as you can see, the organoids
retain the features of the primary tumor.
I like the vimentin as the best marker.
These are very highly vimentin positive in the
original primary tumor, in the organoid, and then the
allograft looks remarkably similar to the
original tumor. So we can actually make that.
Moreover, if you implant those
intracardiac so that you can look at the
metastasis,
you can see that the organoids
develop
metastasis with a very similar frequency as the
original
tumor in the original cells would have.
Okay, so we can model that, but can we study the
heterogeneity of the primary tumors-- excuse me, of
the circulating tumor cells? So to do that,
inspired by our collaboration with a colleague, Peter
Sims, we looked at individual circulating tumor
cells and individual
CTCs, and we isolated those
by FACS to sort individual ones onto a
96-well plate
directly into organoid media, or
onto a plate to be able to sequence them directly.
Okay, so we're sequencing them or we're growing them.
And what we found-- And then we're going to do sequencing
analysis on those and compare them.
So the first point that we found was that even though these were
individual circulating tumor cells and
grown for exactly the same conditions for exactly the same
length of time, you can see how heterogeneous they are.
They look really different, right?
And you can see that there are some very big ones and then some
very tiny ones.
And so there's a great deal of heterogeneity.
So this is just showing you the growth over time.
These are just two examples. You can see there's a
tremendous heterogeneity of the organoids.
You can visually see.
What about molecularly? So molecularly, when we do this
sequencing of those individual organoids, we call
them iOrganoids, you can see that they're not all the same.
They cluster into two components, and actually the ones
that were based on the morphological differences.
We call them big and small because there are big ones and then there are
small ones. And actually, believe it or not, that's the best way to
distinguish them.
And not only that, but when we look at the CTC data
itself and you project the CTC data directly
onto the organoids, they also actually appear the same.
Peter tells me this is quite remarkable how closely they're
aligned, that there really are two different
collections of these.
So we wanted to understand-- Oh, and I wanted to mention that what's really
striking is that a major difference between these
is a hypoxia versus
oxidative phosphorylation. So the big ones are
hypoxic, and the little ones are
focused in ox-phos. And I'll come back to that in a couple slides.
So
we wanted to understand what's
driving... the organoids,
excuse me, what's driving the CTCs?
What are the molecular features that distinguish these CTCs,
especially the CTC heterogeneity?
So to do that, we perform master regulator analysis
of the
data from the individual CTCs. Okay, so these are looking
at the sequences of the individual CTCs.
This is single-cell data on those.
We perform master regulator analysis, and they actually do
cluster into multiple-- You can actually see differences in
the clusters.
And I'm going to draw your attention to this cluster here, which was
very interesting to us for two reasons.
Number one, it tracked exactly with the molecular
heterogeneity that I told you about, and secondly, that it was associated
with adverse clinical outcome. So I'll show you two examples of that.
So here, this is the module
three, and you can see very strong
correlation with what we call the size signature.
So strongly associated with this heterogeneous phenotype.
And also this cluster is very
highly expressed in
metastases versus primary tumors, looking
both in
bulk seq. We also have single-cell data, and also
very interesting data set that we received from Dan
Haber's group,
David Miyamoto, where you can see a
very strong correlation of expression of this
cluster in CTCs, single-cell data from
CTCs versus primary tumors from the same patients,
also associated with adverse clinical outcome.
So then we wanted to ask which of the genes
or master regulators within this complex were driving the
phenotype that we were most interested in seeing.
And so we depleted them individually,
injected those in CTC organoid lines that we made,
injected those, and looked at tumor growth,
metastases, or the number of CTCs.
Now remember, we don't want something that's driving the tumor growth down,
right? We want tumor growth to be the same.
We want to see differences in the number of CTCs and
hopefully metastasis as well, because that would be functional CTCs.
So among these, the gene that really caught our eye was
TMPO.
So TMPO, as I'll tell you a little bit more about it,
didn't affect tumor growth virtually at all, but it did
result in a significant decrease in metastasis and a
significant decrease in the number of CTCs in
circulation. And to do a deeper
dive into that, I want to show you data both from subcutaneous and
intracardiac. And as you can see,
in subcutaneous assays, you can see a
very striking reduction in the number of
circulating tumor cells,
and also correspondingly in the metastasis score
in both assays. So they really affect metastases,
particularly, by the way, metastases to bone.
So with Max
and colleagues at
Cornell, we looked at the expression levels of TMPO in
human
prostate cancer. And as you can see, the expression levels are
much
stronger,
and also much more nuclear
excuse me, in disease progression.
And with Avery, we looked at expression in circulating
tumor cells from patients with advanced prostate
cancer. These are patients with castration-resistant prostate cancer.
And you can see that TMPO is strikingly strongly
expressed, actually in a very large percentage of
the cells, and also co-expressed with lamin, which is
another nuclear marker. Actually, I'm sorry, I should have mentioned
that TMPO is a nuclear
membrane-associated protein. It's actually is called
LAP2 or Lamin-Associated Protein 2.
Okay. So the really cool thing was we were thinking about, well, how
is TMPO doing this? So we noticed, first of all, that it's
very strongly associated in terms of its
activity with the big organoids. Very strongly
associated. And you can actually see that either
by overlaying it on the expression or by looking at a
correlation of TMPO activity and organoid area
size. When you knock down TMPO, the organoid size
decreases significantly.
And that is, in a nutshell, is primarily
due to a shift from hypoxic to
a ox phos program. And with our colleague, Christina
Chiou, we were able to
look at the consequences of TMPO
knockdown for
oxidative phosphorylation,
as well as for hypoxia or growth or stability
in hypoxia conditions. A very striking
decrease, even in vitro.
So
basically what I've shown you is that we can learn about how cells
can transit in circulation, and
how they can survive. So what we think TMPO is doing as a
nuclear regulatory protein is
allowing the cells to survive the stress.
We also have evidence that it's allowing the cells to survive at the
metastatic site, and to actually find their home at the
metastatic site. So we think this is a very interesting novel
mechanism, but hopefully, as you can see,
we can only have found this by looking in vivo and by
looking specifically for what's required for
heterogeneity.So I'm at the end of my time here.
So I'm just going to tell you that this is Arihanna here, who really
spearheaded all of this effort. These are all the beautiful people in
my lab.
And I really want to mention collaborations from Michael Shen's group,
the Califano group, particularly Alec Go, who did all of that.
Peter Sims is the lead author on this paper with
me and really a fantastic collaborator.
I mentioned Christine, I mentioned Dan and David,
I mentioned Max and Ebi,
and I'm really grateful that we still get funding
. So thank you very much, and very thanks to the mice.
Hi, my name is Hoy Pinyo from Northwestern University.
Mm-hmm.
Great work, Kari. And then you have
found the gene TMPO in single CTCs, and
other studies or our studies have observed a lot of CTCs could
form clusters with-
Mm-hmm
... tumor cells themselves or-
... with immune cells.
Mm-hmm.
Have you also seen a TMPO differential
expression in the clustered CTCs, or if
there is any role for potential regulation in such-
Yeah, that's a great question. So the question is,
what's the expression level of TMPO in clusters
as opposed to in single CTCs? So I sort of
glossed over a lot of the detail in the interest of time, but we
haven't looked at TMPO
expression in the clusters. That's a great idea.
But we have looked at the
individual
versus clusters of CTCs in
our models, and the more highly metastatic, not
surprisingly, have higher clusters.
Now, we intentionally looked at single cells, and
because of that, we didn't look at
the single cells versus the clusters.
It's a very
great question.
Very technically challenging to do, I have to say, because of the way we
did it. But I will tell you that when we're looking
at all organoids from the
whole mouse as opposed to single
organoids,
then we
have been able to look at clusters versus not.
But we haven't looked at TMPO. But it's a very important question you're asking.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Go ahead.
Hi.
That was a very wonderful talk, actually.
Thank you.
I'm curious about the fact that-
Mm-hmm
... there's been lately studies that has established the fact that
there are dormant CTCs as well. So, I
was just wondering if you have looked into that and if you have--
Because you're studying-
Mm-hmm
... heterogeneity in the CTCs,
if you have seen any specific thing that causes that dormancy and
later relapse.
That's a great question. So we think we're able to measure
dormancy.
This is actually not the subject of today's talk, but
since you're asking me, I'll just tell you a little bit.
So early on,
as I mentioned, we can look temporally at metastasis over
time.
Early on, and actually, my postdoc, Alvaro, saw
this in 2013. This was one of the most
earliest observations we had, that we can see
cells, I'll call them disseminated cells, in the bone.
And interestingly, they're in the bone, not in other organs.
Very early on, and they don't form metastases.
So we also have observed independently
a
molecular shift that occurs later.
So there's probably a subgroup of the cells.
By the way, TMPO is probably there.
Mm.
Now, that doesn't answer your question about dormancy because we haven't linked all
that together and shown that those cells are dormant cells.
But if it walks like a duck and quacks like a duck,
it might be a duck.
Yeah.
Right?
But I don't know for sure, okay?
Okay.
Ask me next year.
Sure.
Hi.
Thank you so much, doctor, for very nice modeling.
Mm-hmm.
Actually, in our lab, we are doing on 3D modeling of PDAC
relapse.
Mm-hmm.
The same aims that you are following.
We are working on resistance screening-
Mm-hmm
... and after TCR-T cell based immunotropic
pressure.
Very beautiful. We saw the same observation that you saw after
dispensing the single cells into 96 well plate.
You saw the different size of organoids growing-
Mm-hmm
... heterogenizing size. We saw heterogenizing size, so the
efficiency. Like different
proportion of-
Mm-hmm
... immuno
depletion and immuno
escaping.
Mm-hmm.
So here I have a question. On your previous slide, technical
slide view-
Sure
... that after FACS sorting of your single cells,
technically I want to see how you control this
technical
diversity, the technical errors.
Because one thing is that we can consider that the number of cells that
dispensed or distributed between single loads can be
different and lead to different size of organoid that are growing.
Beside, I want to emphasize that absolutely-
Oh
... site heterogenicity is correct.
But I want to see how much you had control
forequals the number that you distributed or
dispensed between the single wells how many
96-well plate you have been using per each assay
have you controlled your technical errors?
Why don't you let me answer the question?
Yes.
Okay, because I understand your question.
So let me explain how those experiments are done.
We take blood, we
remove the
red blood cells, we deplete that, and then we put it to fax.
So yes, some mice have more CTCs than
other mice, and of course, we've done this in multiple mice.
I think we've done this in five mice. Okay?
They're very heterogeneous across the mice, as I mentioned, I think
a few times in the talk. Now, the way it is done is that we
fax sort, so there's a single cell in each well.
Right.
Okay? That's the whole point, is a single cell in each well.
So that's how we control for the number of cells.
And how we control for the heterogeneity across mice is by doing
different mice.
Right.
So yes.
Thank you so much.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
But the paper is on bioRxiv. You could look up a lot of the details.
Obviously, I can't go into the details since it's flashing red.
But you know what I mean?
Yes. Sure.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Hi. Wonderful talk. Just wanted to understand if you
found the profile differences in those multiple
CTCs with respect to vimentin, because you showed-
That's a great question. Okay. Vimentin is very interesting.
I took it out in the interest of time.
But what's really neat about it is that all of the
metastatic... The model that's very highly metastatic, which is
called the MPK model,
all of those cells express vimentin.
However, not all of those cells are highly
heterogeneous. And so what we think is that vimentin,
and EMT, if you will, is the first step, but it's not
the only step. TMPO is on in a subset of those
cells. It's really cool, actually.
Right. And just quickly, another question is that
between the big and small cells-
Uh-huh
... there was a gradient of multiple sizes.
Yes. Mm-hmm.
Because there could be plenty of data there to explain heterogeneity.
So did you get a chance to look into that?
Yeah. So what's interesting about that,
we're looking for differences. To do molecular analysis, you got to
look for differences and if you go in between.
But what's interesting, yeah, there's quite a range.
Okay.
But they fall into two groups
that you can molecularly characterize that way.
Now, it would be interesting to see if there are variations along the way.
Thank you.
Easier to go back and look at that-
Yes
... than to try to tease it out, if you know what I mean.
But it's a great question.
All right.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you. Can we do a couple more?
We can continue with the questions, but it's now open for all speakers.
Okay. So where did I see?
And there are some questions on the screen.
Maybe I'll
ask a question on the screen, and then we'll go to you.
So
this is for George. What is the proportion of these different organotropic
metastatic clones in a primary tumor, and does it translate
into occurrence and severity of metastasis?
This is a really great question, and
it doesn't have a simple answer. So
when it comes to metastasis severity,
we can definitely predict from the primary tumor
the aggressive clones and whether
the tumor is likely to metastasize.
We would need to do single-cell RNA seq
in order to be able to determine
how many of the primary tumor clones
are closer to the different metastatic clones, which is something we
haven't done. But I suspect that
this is a process that is evolving and
being selected through the process of metastasis, so
I do not anticipate that we will see marked differences in the
primary tumor.
So I have a
question for... So the question for the last speaker really is,
in the last few years, there have been these stories coming out from the
Rabinowitz Lab, D. Berardinelli's group, arguing
that the classical Warburg effect might not
explain metastasis. Right? So there are
instances where the metastatic cells actually have upregulated
OXPHOS signature. In your case, it looks like it's, again,
going in a very classical direction, where the metastatic cells are more
hypoxic, less OXPHOS.
Can you comment on whether there will be lineage differences, there might be
metabolic differences, and what the drivers are?
Because it doesn't seem like there's a consensus in
terms of how we should be thinking about this.
Yeah. So I think the answer to that is very simple.
It depends on where you're looking and when, and over what time.
So what I think, I'm going to speculate
based on data we have, not all
confirmed is what I mean. Okay? But basically,
when the cells are in circulation,
they're in a very hostile environment, a low
oxygen environment. They need to be able to
survive in that hostile environment.
They need to survive in hypoxic conditions. Okay?
Once they get to the tumor, then the environment is going to
change, and then they're going to need... Not the tumor, the distant site.
The environment's going to change, and they're going to need differences.
So I would speculateThat something like TMPO
could help it to work depending upon the environment,
because there are multiple isoforms and they probably do different things
at different times. Does that make sense?
And I think that may explain. So it's not like it's
always
one thing or another. It needs to
survive in the context in which it's faced.
Yeah. I think I agree with you. I'm just thinking experimentally.
Perhaps we should then start thinking in terms of the continuum of the metastatic-
Yeah. That's what I just said. I wasn't talking about experimental, I was talking
about life. Yes.
So.
I think whether it's in the EMT state, the MET state, or living in the
circulating-
I don't think talking about states.
I think talking about understanding the environment that they're in makes a
lot more sense than trying to put a square peg in a round hole.
So maybe it's not simply EMT, or maybe the terms are what
the problem is, not what's actually happening.
It's an evolving dynamic situation,
and the cells have to survive there.
Hi, my name is Esther Shi from Cellensia.
Great work on the CTC organoids. I have two questions.
One is that, is TMPO also a driver
to make those cells be able to make themselves, into the
bloodstream, become the CTC? The second thing is we are also
growing a lot of CTC organoids, but we have
a lot of them actually enter quiescence after three months.
Mm-hmm.
I'm curious,
how long you can get your CTC-
Yeah
... organoid to grow.
Oh, those are human? Are those from human or mouse?
Human.
Yeah. So I think that's going to be the difference, is human and mouse.
Oh.
Okay. We
have not had any, knock on wood,
you're going to jinx me. We have not had any
problems keeping cells viable. But again, that's
mouse, not human.
Okay.
And the second one was?
The first one is, is TMPO the driver to make the cells-
That's a great-
... as a CTC? Yeah.
That's a great question. I don't have direct evidence for that.
I think it's a very important contributor.
I
couldn't tell you it is the driver, if you know what I mean.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Great talk. I'm Neil Ruthan from Memorial Sloan Kettering.
So I really appreciated your focus on the transcriptomic
adaptations for circulating tumor cells, but
I'm wondering if you've looked into whether there are genetic
determinants-
That's a great question
... for some of these adaptations.
Yeah, that's a great question. So
genetic or epigenetic? We're doing the epigenetic now.
So one of the major limitations of working
with genetically engineered mouse models is they don't make
genomic alterations, so there's not a lot of
genomic alterations.
Having said that, in prostate cancer, there aren't a lot of genomic alterations,
so it might not be so relevant.
But
that's just a feature of the models.
Even the most highly aggressive, there aren't a lot of genomic alterations.
That's fine. Thank you.
I interject with a small question from the
screen. Do big and small CTCs show
organotropism?
Oh, yes.
But next year I'll tell you about that.
Tell whoever's on the line next year. Okay.
I don't know who it is.
Okay.
Hi, my name is Bekir Chinar, and then we are actually working on the
CTC, but a different approach. I really thank you very much for those actually,
the high content data and then in vivo conditions.
And then what we have found, actually support my
question, that we took, for example, prostate cancer Alan cap
cell and used actually that circulate in the bioreactor.
Microgravity bioreactor, we actually went through the four
generations,
and then we saw that actually every generations,
because the objective is to how many cells actually
survive on that condition, and also
what are the actual stem cell, the makeup of those cells.
What we found, every generation, the actual stem cell markers are
changing. I'm wondering whether when you take, for example,
some of your
circulating tumor cells that
generating basically organoids.
If you do basically
sequential growth, do you see any changes in the stem
cell marker expression or growth pattern?
Because we also saw the actual growth pattern also decline,
actually increase and decrease. And some of the actually
not even growing anymore, and then also actually become static,
and maybe that's part of the actual maybe reason is the called
dormancy. Do you see the similar pattern if you actually grow, maybe you did
one cycle, if you go actually further cycle, like you go up
to four cycle, what do you see in the actual growth pattern, gene
expression pattern, and then the stem cell makeups?
Thank you.
What was the question? I don't really understand the question.
The question is, have you looked at the stem cell expression
on those?
But you were talking about cycles. Cycle of what? Cycle of what?
Cycling. For example, if you take some what we have done, we put
actually the Alan cap cell-
Mm-hmm
... into bioreactor, take it out-
Mm
... grow it, put it back into it.
Ah.
Take it out-
You mean sequential?
... grow it back into it. We went actually four generation.
Every generation, actually, the stem cell markers changing,
so is growth as well.
That's a very interesting experiment, but I didn't show you anything in which we've
done multiple rounds of it. Do you know what I mean?
We have not cycled it like that, so we haven't
selected
for that, so I couldn't answer your question. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
We need to close, but if you have a very quick question, you can.
Sure.
So, thank you for all the three presentation.
I think it shed great bit of light in terms of the molecular mechanism of
metastasis. My question is this
migration of cancer cells from the site to
the other parts of the organ, is it purely driven from the
need of energetics like metabolism, or
what are the key determinants of it, and why these cells
preferentially metastasize certain organs,
not all organs equally?
This guy's good.
You want to take it?
Yeah.
Well, I think it's a combination of things.
And it's a combination of being an aggressive
tumor cells, being able to metastasize at different organs, but
also having the capacity to disseminate in the
metastatic organ and whether its metabolism
can
flourish in the new
environment. Yeah.
And probably the second question, what are the therapeutic potential of some of
these findings, like the translation to the therapy,
some of the findings that you guys discussed today?
When it
comes to organ-specific
metastasis?
Not really only organ-specific metastasis.
Let's say TMPO expression
has been correlated to the aggressiveness of
the tumor. So is it like editing of that
particular locus can be critical
for
coming up with a treatment for human metastasis is what I mean?
The locus of TMPO, is it
altered in
tumors that are more prone to metastasis?
Not that I know of, but-
The TMPO expression?
At the site, the genetic site that we're talking about.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, the genome. No. This is
going to be post-trans. This is not a genomic change,
no. It's expression.
It's expression.
Okay. Sorry, we have to end, but I'd like to thank the speakers for-
Thank you, Mr. Lee, for coming
... a great session and thanks for coming.